so it's a day that tennis and everybody
has been dreading the ends of Roger
Federer's tennis career and Roger I've
covered a lot of retirements and there's
always a lot of tears but you seem quite
at peace with your decision how hard was
it to make how did you make it
there were tears of course you know when
I let my uh friends and family or my my
friends know or when they're ultimately
also the decision was taken with the
team that I think we've come to the to
the end of it all you know and it's been
a wonderful moment uh you look back at
all the the great things we have
achieved together and that it's okay to
step away you know and uh
have others do their magic you know on a
tennis court and not maybe me so much
anymore
um on the tour and everything so
um it's been hard you know of course but
I could see it also coming the last few
years it's been not easy
um playing so little rehabbing all the
time and uh coming to the realization
um was only but logical for me also at
some point so I am really much at peace
like you said
horse Arena now you it is the end of an
era what have you both brought to the
sport do you think different things for
sure you know but at the end we both
dated as moms and dads you know funny to
think think of that because both When
We're Young made it on tour and never
thought we're probably going to end as
as that at the end
um I think we were definitely the bridge
you know for a very long time from the
old generation to the new generation
which I think has been a privilege for
me to play across Generations like this
same for her
um
and she brought the power game in like
no other so she's been obviously
instrumental with that and being a game
changer is something
um
that I think is the ultimate compliment
I don't know if I did that in any way
but I did my way and I I hope people
enjoyed watching me play for so long